TOBIAS NOKE: Thank you, Sarah.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Tobias Noke, and I'm
a BD manager for Google Play,
working with our key
partners in western Europe.
It's great to be here
with you at Playtime,
and to see so many new
and familiar faces.
After we have been
discussing how
to de-risk your game launch,
let's take the next step.
Let's think about you want
to take your game out there
to the crowds.
And for doing so,
you want to build
a strong and engaged community.
Because only with a community,
your game can last for years.
And when it comes
about communities,
YouTube is the place to be.
Because YouTube, well, that's
the biggest video platform
for games out there.
Today, we will hear two
impressive strategies
from Paul Gouge, the
CEO of Playdemic,
who will tell us how we can
get our users to keep and share
their favorite
moments on YouTube.
And from Mickey Elimelech
the CMO of Space
Ape Games, who knows everything
about working with influencers.
But before letting
them on stage,
let me give you some
more background on why
YouTube matters for your game.
YouTube is essentially
where your users are.
Whether you do a core game,
a casual game, a game where
they are, a game with VR, you
will find the users on YouTube.
You can acquire
users on YouTube.
And you can speak to
them again and again
to ensure that they are engaged.
And to put this
into perspective,
last year we had
507 billion views
of gaming content
on YouTube alone.
And the good news here, for
everyone in this room is,
this growth is driven
by mobile games.
In the last two years, we have
been seeing an increase of 342%
when it comes to the hours
watched of mobile gaming
content.
So this will become more
and more relevant in future.
And last but not
least, everything
moves towards live gaming
and live streaming.
We also see an increase
of 512% year over year
when it comes to live
gaming on YouTube.
So YouTube is big.
YouTube is relevant.
And it's growing.
But all of these
numbers do not really
help if we do not know who
is actually on the platform.
We have done some research and
identified three key audiences.
One are the trendsetters.
Those guys are basically
YouTube to just find out
whether they should
download or pay for a game.
Half of them are actually
waiting for new game videos
to be released.
So to get these
trendsetters on board,
you need to have a
compelling video strategy,
and release videos again
and again and again.
Second, we have
identified the people who
love game and video culture.
Those users are mainly
in for great videos.
80% of them just love videos
because of great soundtrack,
great visuals, and great story.
So ensure your videos are good,
have a high production quality,
or at least a very good
story, because this way
you get the game
culture lovers on board.
And last but not least,
we identified the people
who love to reconnect
and who love to share.
Those users, basically just
videos because somebody else
shared it with them.
And if they're in the pub, and
hear about a game, 62% of them
will directly go to
YouTube to research
what this game is all about.
So so much for the growth of
YouTube and the size of YouTube
and also the key
audiences on YouTube.
And you want to get all of them.
But before doing so, you need
to set up your game properly
for YouTube.
You need to integrate mechanics,
which enable the users to share
their favorite moments.
So let me get
someone on stage who
can explain this much
better than I do,
the CEO of Playdemic,
my friend Paul Gouge.
PAUL GOUGE: Apparently I can
explain it better than Toby.
That is quite a lofty goal
there, but I am going to try.
I am going to talk about a
game called Golf Clash today.
Hands up here if you
have played Golf Clash?
Kids.
Quite a few of you.
That's good to hear.
And hands up if you shared
a video in Golf Clash?
Oh, some polite people
saying they have.
Well, people do.
So that is what we are
going to talk about today.
So, one of the things we've
just heard there about YouTube
as a platform and about videos
generally, is obviously,
we now know we exist
in a world where people
want to share their moments.
Where people want to reach
out in that community
and express how they
feel about a product,
and those great
periods of excitement
they've experienced
within that product.
So when it came to
building Golf Clash,
we really wanted to, for the
first time really in Playdemic,
to embrace that.
And to give players
an opportunity
to make this really
super easy for them.
We know, you know, the
advocates, the highly engaged
players, will go out of
their way to share video.
They'll go out of their
way to store and share
and, actually, overcome
some quite difficult
technical challenges.
But what we wanted
to do was create
something that
really would appeal
to the mass market
in that sense.
So in terms of the whys, this
was very much a business goal.
You know, we had just been
talking about de-risking
our businesses.
A lot of that is focused
around those core metrics
of commercialization,
of engagement,
monetization of retention.
What we wanted to
do is also build
in there another crucial
metric, which we didn't really
talk about this morning, is
redriving your organic reach
and getting your users
to really empower
the community by reaching out
and telling about the product.
So very much this was
about stimulating installs,
stimulating the retentive
and engaging quality
of sharing those moments.
To think about how we can
harness those platforms.
We just heard very much
about the scale of YouTube.
We all know that.
It's a significant
scale platform.
And when you think about
what we're doing when
we are spending money on UA.
We are essentially century
creating those moments.
We're creating moments on
platforms like Youtube,
that really sell
our game quality
and sell those key moments.
What better way to
do that than to have
a player do that for you?
We all know the most powerful
form of recommendation
comes from an individual
that you are interested in
or care about, have some
relationship with, rather
than necessarily just
thinking about UA.
Also, we wanted to make sure
that those moments in the game
were the key emotional moments.
We wanted to make sure that we
made that piece easy, as well,
for the player.
So those real flag-bearing
moments for that product.
The bits that, I think, Jens
referred to this morning
about those bits that
make the players excited.
We wanted to make
sure the players could
share those moments as well.
And also, and this is very much
an ancillary benefit, but also
in customer support and
caring for our users
long term, is a crucial element
and one of the great side
effects we found
from our integration,
is it actually gave us an
opportunity for customer
support to be able to look
easily at the experiences
that our players were
having in that moment.
So thinking about
the player goals.
For us, we know as players,
everyone in this room
is a player of video
games, I'm sure.
And we all love the
industry that we're in.
And we also love the product.
And we want to
share those moments,
you know, particularly in skill
games, like Golf Clash is.
We want to share
how good we are.
with the community
that we've done something
special or something funny
or something different
or something new.
We want to reach out to the
community and share that.
We also want to make
sure that we can
store those moments as well.
And that we can favorite them.
Now we have a language
now of sharing
in our global digital economy.
We wanted to make sure
that was in this product.
So what does that look like?
I mean, hopefully those
of you who have played it
will recognize the
UI of Golf Clash.
So what we did is
we created a system
where every single shot
you ever take in Golf Clash
is stored for you.
So there was no need
for you to anticipate.
And if you think about the
illogical nature of this,
you know, you can
never anticipate when
this great moment is coming.
So you can't sort of
get to a place thinking,
I'm going to have an
awesome game today.
I am going to make
sure I'm videoing it.
Now that can't happen.
Even in the live environment,
where you are live streaming,
you can't guarantee that those
moments are going to happen.
So what we wanted to do
is to make it foolproof.
We wanted to make
sure that we were
going to store every single
shot you ever took in the game.
So we created-- and to
give it some importance--
we stuck this right on
the main HUD of the game.
The replay sat there alongside
all the other key functions
of the game, to say,
this is something
that's always going be
tracking your movements,
always going to be
tracking your key shots.
We also, then, gave
you the opportunity
to automatically store
things that we thought
were interesting and
automatically favorite them.
So we have some
logic in the game,
that when you do something
that we generally
think is interesting
from a skill perspective,
we'll automatically share the
piece of UI you're seeing here
that says, look, you
know you just did
something that was pretty cool.
We know from the way
the game is played
and from our data, that
the thing you just did
requires quite a
lot of the skill.
So we are going to pop
this up straight away,
and say, here's
something that you
might be interested in sharing.
You might certainly be
interested in watching it back
initially.
And then you may going
to want to share that.
So we have a UI here
that is, again, as I say,
is accessible from the HUD.
It allows you to go through
all the shots you've taken.
Allows you to replay
them to yourself.
Allows you to rename
them, to give them
a cool name that might
be interested as a hook
when you share that
out into YouTube.
And to watch them
back and share them
at any point in the journey.
So we allow a lot of storage in
the app for players to do this.
So any point in time,
in any future date,
where you are having a sort of
a trade-off with a buddy who
has shared something
interesting,
you think you got one
better, you can go back
into your library, you can name
that, you can share that out
again.
So really low friction on
the part of the player.
You will all be familiar with
what the google interface looks
like for sharing.
But it is, it's a
very simple mechanic.
It's built into the product.
If you're not using
it, please do so.
We've certainly seen
it to be something
that's been very easy
for us to integrate with.
Obviously it's both
live and historic.
So in terms of other
considerations,
this is just a bit of detail.
I'm conscious I've
got eight minutes.
I think my wife said
to me this morning,
you've never spoke eight
minutes by anything.
So I'm going to try to
keep it pretty punchy.
But one of the things
we wanted to do
is, in recording that
video, we didn't really
feel that we could just
share the raw data.
So when you look- when
we started to do this,
we looked back at some of
the feeds we were creating.
And they're quite dull.
There was quite a lot of moments
in the game-- and those of you
have played it will
recognize this-- where
you are kind of setting
up a shot, you're aiming,
and then in replay, that
really didn't look good.
So we wanted to bring sort
of an element of pre-edit
to the experience.
So we cut out quite
a lot of dead space.
And we said, this
isn't interesting.
This isn't something
that people are
going to want to relate to when
it gets out onto to YouTube.
What we also did is, and
this goes back to the point
I was making about
UA, we also integrated
an intro and an end card.
So you know, from
the perspective,
this is also a piece
of real estate for us,
reaching out into
that huge community
that Toby talked about to
drive installs and engagement.
We wanted to make sure
the brand was there,
and there was a
key call to action.
So everything we stored
for you also has the intro
and endcard on it.
We also, as I mentioned already,
allowed favoriting of shots
yourself.
So in that little library
I showed you in the UI,
you can favorite a
shot at any point,
which puts it in a separate
part of that storage system.
So you can go back and
look your favorite shots
and edit that and
curate that yourself.
And also as I mentioned, that
automatic favoriting of shots
as well.
To ensure that the
game is telling you
this is something interesting.
This is something that you
should think about sharing,
because you did
something special here.
And you know, finally, the
ability to store replays.
I think when I
created this, we said
we were storing a hundred shots.
We're actually allowing you to
store a bit more than that now.
So what does this
mean in terms of data?
Some boring graphs for you.
But quite interesting.
I think what you're
seeing here is
that these are the share
opportunities per DAU
So you can see that,
roughly speaking,
we are right about
one share opportunity
for every single
DAU in the game.
Now clearly, that's in some
respects, a meaningless mean.
So some players are getting
lots share opportunities.
Some are getting none.
But ultimately
overall, we're creating
many, many opportunities to
share that are automated.
That are using the system.
This is not
somebody, and again I
stress this, having to
go away, think about
how they're going to
record their video,
think about how they're
going to share it.
This is the game you're
saying to them, to one person,
effectively every day, here's
a way you can share a video.
Here is something
interesting you
can put out into the community.
And what we see
is that around 15%
of those people who have a share
opportunity go on an share it.
Now which is a pretty
impressive conversion rate.
Now we all think about
conversion rates on lots
of our metrics in this world.
And to get 15%
from something that
isn't initiated by you, that
is initiated by the game,
is a pretty powerful
level of conversion.
And what's interesting to us,
is that stayed very consistent.
So you can see,
obviously, now, the launch
spike at the beginning.
But this is a game now
with many millions of DAU,
that's keeping a very stable
ability to keep converting
those videos to shares.
And you can see
what we've also done
as well, is that has
grown consistently
as the game has grown.
So many, many numbers
of shares going out
and keeping that
consistent conversion rate.
Which is, of course,
driving engagement
amongst our existing user base.
But as importantly, continuing
to drive the organic installs
of people seeing this for the
first time, with an end card,
in a curated manner,
shared by somebody
that they're interested
in a community they're
interested in.
So overall, what
we've seen so far,
these are the very,
very headline metrics.
Is we've seen a
significant conversion
of those opportunities en masse.
And as I mentioned before,
that 15% is increasing overall.
So you are seeing a start point
there and an improving outcome.
And I think I'm
doing OK for time.
So the result obviously here,
is these are just replays.
So close to 100,000 replays
if I do the screen shot,
on YouTube of people
that have shared that out
into the community.
So that's it for me.
I think I just about
did it in eight minutes.
MICKEY ELIMELECH: Thanks, Toby.
I don't know about
Masters, but we'll try.
So hi, everyone, I'm Mickey.
I head up the marketing
team at Space Ape Games.
And for those of you
who don't know us,
we are a London-based
mobile gaming studio.
We have four live games,
Samurai Siege, Rival Kingdoms,
Transformers Earth Wars, and
Fastlane Road to Revenge.
We, as a company, our
mission is to create
a genre-defining top
game, so we actually
have additional five teams
working on new titles
at the moment.
Today, I'm here to talk to you
about a really great campaign
that we did for the launch
of Fastlane Road to Revenge.
And through that,
hopefully, show you
how we think about influences
and why we do what we do.
So we think of ourselves as
a community-first developer.
We think that a lot
of our big breaks
came from genuinely
listening to our players
and allowing them to inform
how we make our games
and how we develop our games.
We found that by involving
top players and influencers
from the very, very, very
early stage of development--
when I mean early stage,
I mean, very early
in the the development.
The game is not nearly as
polished or anything like that.
But we find that
by doing that, they
helped us understand
what would make
the game interesting
for their communities.
And then they became
our ambassadors.
So we really kind of realized
that we're on to something--
some really strong
marketing tool here.
So we ended up going and using
this in every single game
launch that we've had since.
To give you some example,
for Rival Kingdoms,
we were working on some big
innovations in build-in battle
genre.
So we needed a live community
to feedback on everything
that we were doing.
We recruited about 100 top
players and gaming influencers
to do that for us.
And they helped us
really shape the game.
For Transformers Earth
Wars, for instance, we
involved some big fan sites
and some gaming influencers,
and they helped us do
all of the onboarding
process into the
game, and really
bridge between those fans of the
IP and the built-in battle play
genre.
But it became harder and harder
to reach those big influencers.
And all the interactions
were becoming
very much transactional based.
We did a few of these for the
launch of Transformers Earth
Wars, and actually did
paid content for that.
But what we found is when
someone was making videos
that they weren't really
passionate about the game
that they were promoting,
it had two main problems.
One, it didn't
drive any results.
So it didn't really
justify us doing it again.
And two, their community
picked up on the fact
that they're not being genuine.
And so they were
losing credibility.
So in our opinion, this
isn't a sustainable way
of doing things.
Rather, we think
that content creation
should be a product of a
meaningful relationship that
really offers
something genuinely
interesting for the
influencer, without asking
for anything in return.
They have to work
really hard these days
to keep their channels engaged,
to keep their channels growing,
to provide their fans
reasons to come back again
and again and again.
And we have to be a lot
more creative these days,
and think right from
the start of things
that would create that
inherent interest for them.
Paul was talking
about watchability.
But also things like
integrating them into the game.
Offering them exclusive and
unique content, and things
like that.
That will actually make
them create content for you,
but not because you
gave them a brief
and you paid them
pay them some cash,
but because they're
genuinely interested,
and they genuinely are excited
about their involvement
in your game.
So how does this
all come together
for the launch of Fastlane?
We created a unique
opportunity to get
be integrated into the
game as a quest giver,
and give out jobs
that were based
on real-life interactions and
their Youtube personalities.
By doing that, we ended
up having 21 big YouTubers
integrated into the game, with
over 50 million subscribers
in total.
What we did at launch
was a week-long event
that had all of them featured.
They all kind of
participated in that event.
And then after that, we had
every single weekend an event
that was either an individual
event or a collaboration
between some Youtubers.
And what that resulted
in is tons and tons
of videos and social posts all
really promoting passionately
their involvement in the game.
I've got some examples of the
best executions for you guys
here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- What's up, everybody?
Boo Tramp here.
And welcome back to another
video on my channel.
So today we're
playing more Fastlane.
It's an absolutely
insane game that
has just come out from
the amazing guys over
in Space Aid Games.
- All you do is put your
finger, your thumb, your toes,
your nose, anything
on the screen.
- The game carries a
Fastlane, put me in the game.
And it was a good time.
- And today, we are doing
something really special.
We're going to be
doing some of my event.
- Now every week, there's
going to be a new job.
And it's Youtuber related.
so your favorite Youtuber
is pretty much in this game.
- It's a voodoo doll, and I
will use it now to control you.
- I'm evil now, Jordan.
You've taken my soul.
- It is evil now.
We need to kill it.
All the voodoo dolls.
- And I'll say the magic
words to undo the voodoo.
Last one, [INAUDIBLE].
OK, we have completed
the next mission.
- The thing you've got to do
here is collecting 200 chests.
Yes, we are-- and there
is the [INAUDIBLE]
to collect me some chest.
Oh, yeah, look at that, guys.
I'm collecting all
that good stuff.
- Or if I go for
something else, ah,
that rocket came
out of nowhere, son.
- Oh, yes.
Level 37, I'm almost
level 40, and then I
can get a new car, which
is called the [INAUDIBLE]..
- Oh, did you guys see that?
[END PLAYBACK]
MICKEY ELIMELECH: Cool.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
So really, in
terms of results, I
think the most impressive
fact is that at launch week,
this was our second
biggest marketing channel.
It yielded hundreds of
thousands of installs.
And more than that, it created
six months' worth of content
for us for events in the game.
It drove the most engaged
players, as you can see,
from the D1 retention numbers.
This is a direct product of
that passion that came across
from the Youtuber
to the community,
really engaging them, getting
them to go in the game.
Check them out as quest givers.
And engage and experience
the game for themselves.
They weren't the
biggest of spenders,
but that's probably
because of the age skew.
I think if I summarize
it all, was it worth it?
Absolutely.
Definitely, if you've got
volumes in mind for launch.
But if I can leave you
with one thing, it's this.
Please don't take this
specific example as a template.
It's not a template.
It's all about creating
those relationships.
It's all about thinking about
unique and genuine interactions
with them.
And we believe that we need
to rethink this, and reinvent
this for every single game.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]